he is the star of cnbc's money court he
is also a shark in shark tank which is
nominated for every single last thing
that
needs to be nominated for uh he was on
the show uh in person about four years
ago and he called in a couple times
including this one kevin o'leary back
here in the rich housing show how are
you doing kevin
great to be here thank you great to have
you here where have i called where where
where have i found you where are you in
these uh this great north america where
are you kevin where have i found you
well i'm in transit right now actually
on my way to new york so okay we've got
a big airing of our second episode of
money court i'm excited about it tonight
so um what why did you why did you
decide to take on yet even more
for you to do kevin for something like
this what do you do this for it you know
i do this all day long rich i i have
thirty plus companies and every day
in you know the trials and tribulations
particularly in the last year and a half
i've got some companies that having
euphoric outcomes in one day and others
that are in a catastrophe catastrophe
through litigation or whatever so i'm
constantly
arbitrating situations i do this every
single day and so what we've done here
you're probably aware that in in our
court system over the last year and a
half we've got a massive log jam of
thousands of cases that are not going to
get to trial and yet there's serious
litigation going on here that's
destroying businesses so this is a this
is a court show not like any other this
is not about the dog barking or eating
your homework or something this is this
is real litigation where people are
suing each other and it's very very
difficult sometimes to watch this happen
it just tears families apart tears
customers apart would come it's it's
it's crazy stuff and it's very
compelling
and they agree to abide by the decision
uh of the money court regardless so
here's what we've got here's what we've
got it's a rather remarkable outcome yes
you're in you you sued somebody you you
have now
you have litigants they're suing very
they're in the queue in the court system
they realize that maybe years before
their trials hurt but they've got to get
a resolution they have to find somebody
they trust arbitrate the case what i've
assembled is a really great team i've
got adipose who's a federal judge she
sat on the bench
she's got a
meter like you've never seen she really
knows when someone's lying to her and
i've also got katie fang who's an actual
trial attorney so they've got the law
nailed down they read the case they see
the docket they tell me what the law
says i should do but i don't always
listen to that i have the final decision
i want to save the business i want to do
what's right to save a business that has
employees it's got customers and
shareholders so i'm gonna find that
middle ground and the remarkable
situation is these litigants sign that
arbitration agreement that contract
and as one said to me look i don't
really like you mr wonderful but i trust
you
and i like that i'd rather be trusted
than win a popularity contest
okay
so um
you know it's interesting we could have
had you if if the case of aaron rodgers
versus the green bay packers from uh
april all the way through to about july
was in front of you where there's an
ironclad contract between aaron rodgers
and the green bay packers but he wants
more of a say in the business
um is that something that uh obviously
they're not suing each other but that is
a dispute that we could have used you mr
wonderful kevin o'leary to sort of knock
some heads together i think that would
have been good
you know i would have loved that case
aaron rodgers kicked my ass on jeopardy
i'd love to get that
so
some of these things aren't completely
impartial there is a little bit of the
personal that comes into something like
this no no no listen the truth is when i
have to actually judge a case
where people you know these cases i
gotta tell you something i've made i
made a lot of television in my time you
have and we were rehearsing for this
getting the right past and in all the
cases teeth up yes we get into the
studio we shot this thing in nbc
universal telemundo in miami which is
i've never seen a studio like that it's
the size of an airport it's all digital
it's state of the art they did the
olympics out of there it is the best
studio in the world and so maybe you're
a hundred people on the set now when
these professionals come in they make
television their jaundice their the
studio people the sound people the
lighting people the gaffers
the catering the makeup all that maybe a
hundred maybe 120 i don't know a lot of
people
and so you know they they make the tv
they don't watch it they make it they're
running the cameras in the soundboards
and everything i look over to my right
and every room has a line feed monitor
because when you're shooting this with
multiple cameras there's an editor in
the truck making a quick line feed for
reference and it's coming across all the
studio space i look over to my right in
the middle of a case and there's 20
professionals there glued to the line
feed monitor they're not at the sound
board anymore they're on they're
watching the show they should be making
the show not watching the show and then
at the break the woman that does my
makeup comes up to me says
you're a hole i hated the way you
adjudicated that case you didn't give
enough money to the daughter and i
thought to myself she's totally engaged
we got a hit we got a monster hits when
the people that are making the tv are
watching the tv you got a hit and that's
exactly what's happening so when you're
being told you're being an a-hole does
that mean deep down kevin o'leary you
know you're doing your job properly like
is that dude is that how you receive
doing the right thing you know the thing
i am because if if and when they take
when they do the exit interviews with
the people that now have to abide by my
ruling yes they asked ninety percent of
them said they were okay with it and in
most cases nobody was happy that means i
did a great job
everybody left something on the table
that's a good outcome a new episode of
money court uh tonight and every
wednesday on cnbc at 10 p.m eastern time
with kevin o'leary of uh money court
joining me here on the rich eyes and
show and of course of of shark tank
how did you find alex rodriguez when he
showed up on shark tank uh kevin o'leary
what'd you think of a rock
i've i've worked with alex before we've
done a lot of stuff together he's been
on shark tank multiple times very
interesting guy uh
major focus is real estate that's what
he does okay you know each of these
sharks or guest sharks have a vertical
that their specialty in and he's a real
estate guy that's what he knows so he's
a cash flow guy real estate guy real
estate's all about sir you know
servicing debt on these buildings and
getting cash payments so that's his
specialty and i think it's good to bring
these different disciplines onto the
shark tank because it keeps it
interesting so does it it was a threat
in a way to barbara corcoran as to what
she used to do or that she just sticked
a rod aside pretty much when it come
down to that
no i mean i think those two are as close
as they could be because they know each
other from previous years and
particularly
new york real estate in fact they've
done a couple of deals together in
apartment buildings now barbara's
special i've known her a long time she's
a great cook when i go to new york we
get together i'm a chef too
and we enjoy each other's company but i
must tell you something the only reason
she gets the shark tank on time and
we're in the middle of shooting season
13 right now yes as i bought her new
broom
i think i saw that coming
i've been saying that for years
i know she does actually find that joke
funny i've seen her actually laugh at it
because you know i as you know that what
what troubles her yes she has no
comeback that's the problem it kills her
well i mean just you know uh i i guess
they just expect it from you kevin you
know what i mean like they just they see
that one coming and
you know and so i get it
what is your um your your shark tank
acquisition business deal you're most
proud of most successful as you and i
are talking right now
kevin
well if you measure it by return on
investment it has to be plated it's the
largest exit in shark tank history 340
million cash the company was bought by
albertsons after amazon bought whole
foods they wanted a digital strategy it
was one of the companies that was doing
meal kits it had kitchens in chicago new
york and la we've been spending a lot of
time and money building that up
and uh they bought it and i think what's
so interesting is that that was the
beginning of the whole digital movement
direct to consumer in the food space
very early on and those are a couple of
guys who came out shark tank with
nothing they became multi-millionaires
in 36 months and so it does happen on
shark tank these outcomes are
extraordinary you've had many others
we've sold billions of dollars of the
products and services we've made
countless millionaires and you know it's
it's a really in its 13th year there's
no platform like that you get a hundred
million eyeballs seeing your product or
service after a year of syndication you
can't buy that anywhere and so and the
sharks have millions of followers i'm
able to invest in a business reduces
customer acquisition cost tell the story
of what they do
and i think i think in the long run it
it goes on forever because it's
it's an iconic platform now it does
something that's really great it helps
people realize the american dream
there's nothing wrong with that and you
you guys were nominated uh for a reality
competition show and then outstanding
hosts as well um
for is that the first time that you were
nominated for the hosting gig or has
that happened before no i think it's our
third time for hosting
we're being optimistic if you think i'm
bad now if i win that emmy oh
it's going to be horrible
oh man i i just was going for the fact
that you know in terms of uh folks don't
see this very much but those who vote do
see a four-year consideration video
that's put out there um and there was a
particular host on the zoom this year
for that conversation kevin
um and there is an i and rich and eisen
do i get a little bit of credit for some
of these nominations based on my
stewardship of these conversations
thank you kevin
and if i if i win that emmy we're going
to be friends forever i could tell you i
take it back what if we don't what if
you don't do it
oh
you know i'm just going to have to be an
ostrich with my head in the sand i don't
know i mean i think we
we do a great job on that show one for
emmys for the show and the producers we
think is host you know we've steered
that ship a long time i think we've done
a pretty good job but you never know the
academy has to vote
members are voting i'm hopefully they're
looking at what we've done this year
last year we shot that show in an
extraordinary situation
because of covid we were locked in a
hotel for almost two months
never going outside and we did it safely
nobody got sick and the pandemic was was
raging and i think you gotta ask the
producers to pull that off we have like
220 people on that set everybody getting
tested every day
and so it worked and i think the
television industry has figured out that
maybe covert in one form or another is
going to be around and we haven't we
need new safety protocols
and that's what's going to happen you
know i wanted to i wanted to bring up
one thing rich about tonight's show that
i think you may find
pretty different
there's a case tonight there's a case
tonight that most people think
litigation
is because businesses fail and people
are suing to get the last of the assets
there's a case tonight the craziest
thing i've ever seen
it was a couple of partners and you'll
recognize it right away
that had a business that was
phenomenally successful
pre-tax earnings like i've never seen on
a cash flow basis i didn't even believe
the numbers until i saw the statements i
thought it couldn't be true
and get this
they were suing each other
i thought i was in a different universe
i said who sues out of success you guys
are making a fortune
what are you doing like how is it
possible that you would grind to a halt
and litigate with this much cash flow
flying around
and that's what this case you got to see
it's nuts it's beyond nuts you couldn't
make it up it's so crazy that'll be
tonight at 10 p.m eastern time on cnbc
uh every single wednesday night um
and uh maybe we can have two guys here
uh on my show come in front of your
court if uh one of them doesn't pay off
the bet of giving somebody a breakfast
because their alma mater lost to the
other in the ncaa tournament that's
what's going on here i know that that
might not raise to the level of reaching
the money court uh kevin but um that's
the conundrum i face well no i i'd love
to bring something like that because i
i'd ask adam to put a ropes back on and
throw one of you in jail that would be
fantastic there you go
there you go kevin o'leary ruling from
the bench
thanks for the call kevin let's do this
again anytime i appreciate it take care
be right back right back at you at kevin
o'leary tv twitter and instagram check
him out money court 10 pm eastern
tonight and every wednesday on cnbc hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here